isaac asimov's foundation is perhaps the
most influential science fiction book
series of all time
it details the rise and fall of galactic
society
today we discuss the capital world city
of transform
oh no it's not it's me organism 9186
from the planet trolley on 897 and i'm
back to tell you that this channel
sucks yeah you said that last so you
don't know anything about the foundation
series
actually i'm a big fan of the work of
asimov you're only covering foundation
because the new show's coming out and
you want to get views getting views is
like the whole point of youtube and
anyway i've been covering the foundation
books even before i knew there was a
show
doesn't matter anyway because the new
foundation's gonna be woke garbage just
like june and star wars
gail dornick is being portrayed by a
black woman that matters even more than
leia kinds and dune oh yeah cause i
thought it mattered even less
of course you would say that gail
dornick and leah kinds are both
essential to the plots of both series
and they are both white and male making
them female and black ruins
everything gail dornan doesn't even
exist after like the first few pages of
the first foundation book
they skipped decades and centuries and
he's not even mentioned how would you
even know
because i have the entire foundation
trilogy right here and gail dornick is
not mentioned after the psycho-historian
section of the first
book which is only a few pages and are
you really gonna question me
on dune knowledge i mean i don't mean to
brag but just look at my channel yeah
whatever it's obvious that this is all
just a part of a conspiracy by the media
in liberal hollywood to destroy science
fiction
all the evidence is there you'd have to
be blind not to see it is it though
well duh you just choose to ignore it
because you're a liberal moral okay i
don't have to keep taking this computer
eject
of course rejecting me again because you
can't handle criticism
i can handle criticism just fine but can
you mr organism 9186 from the planet
trollion897
i am a hyper-evolved interdimensional
being i am immune to criticism
all right not very promising but if you
really don't want me to eject you just
sit there and be quiet for a little bit
in fact come sit on the couch
so we were going to focus on the capital
world of asimov's galactic empire
trantor today
but since we've had the intrusion i
think we'll focus on a different topic
to answer the question has science
fiction gone woke we first have to
answer the question what does woke even
mean
i have noticed personally that there are
a few distinct ways in which people use
this word
and two very distinct ways in which i
can identify most
clearly the first is in a positive sense
in this sense the word work refers to a
person that is aware and resistant to
the various social disparities of
society
the other way i see it used is in the
pejorative sense wherein wokeness is
viewed as a form of virtue signaling
a kind of pretentious way of appearing
as though you care about social issues
when you really don't
haha like dennis phil newman apple tv
shut up organism9186
anyway so to answer the question has
science fiction gone woke
we have to figure out which definition
of the word we're actually using
but the problem is most of the time i
have no idea which version of wokeness
that people are referring to
so for the purposes of this video we're
just going to discuss
both now there are a lot of sci-fi names
that people slap the term
woke onto but for the purposes of this
video
i will stick to the ones i know best
dune and foundation
and maybe a little bit of star trek
later on let's start with foundation
since we're already going to talk about
it anyway so as
a organism mentioned azimov's foundation
is being adapted into a tv series
which makes me excited because azimov's
foundation books are some of my favorite
science fiction books to read
i've mentioned before asimov's classic
sci-fi series is set in a gigantic
galactic civilization with 25 million
inhabited worlds
in asimov's foundation books there is a
strong emphasis on human conflict
being resolved without violence one of
asimov's most famous quotes state
violence is the last refuge of the
incompetent
the book prelude to foundation states
that the capital world of trantor
is inhabited by tens of billions of
people and it also states
that the world is full of diversity
bullsh
everyone knows diversity was invented in
2015 by liberal elites too
organism 9186 you were like two seconds
from being ejected
okay in the foundation universe harry
selden is from a planet called helicon
the population of helicon is almost
exclusively white people who are
referred to as westerners
but of course the people of the empire
have no idea why that term is used
because they don't remember old earth
now when seldon goes to trantor he
encounters an asian man named randa for
the first time
and they have this exchange randa
an instructor in psychology was a little
man
short and plump with a round cheerful
face and an almost perpetual smile
he had a sallow complexion and the
narrowed eyes so characteristic of
people on millions of worlds
seldon knew that appearance well for
there were many of the great
mathematicians who had borne it
and he had frequently seen their
holograms yet on helicon he had never
seen one of these
easterners by tradition they recalled
that
though no one knew why and the
easterners themselves were said to
resent the term to some degree
but again no one knew why there are
millions of us here on trantor
randa had said smiling with no trace of
self-consciousness when seldon on first
meeting
had not been able to repress all trace
of startled surprise
you'll also find a lot of southerners
dark skins
tightly curled hair did you ever see one
not on helicon muttered selden all
westerners on helicon a
how dull but it doesn't matter it takes
all kinds
so you can see here in this scene that
selden for the first time is
encountering diversity
he's never even seen an asian person or
a black person before
randa is even taken a bit abacked by the
lack of diversity on helicon
and even calls it dull but ultimately it
doesn't matter because they end up
working together anyway
so isaac asimov was thinking about
diversity in his universe enough to
point out the fact that harry selden
grew as a person after encountering more
diversity asimov was a hippie anyway all
that crap about solutions through
non-violence that doesn't matter anyway
why has laia kinds a white male been
cast as a black female in dune
obviously sjw well first off leo kinds
is half women so not exactly white
and also it didn't really matter to
anyone in david lynch's do when they
cast him as an extremely pale caucasian
david lynch's doom will always be more
true to the book than dennisville noobs
movie
okay vil nerve and no david lynch is
doing is actually highly inaccurate i
did a whole video on the problems with
that movie
in the dune novels the fremen are
descended from the zen sunni wanderers
a people who traveled for centuries
throughout the galaxy facing new
oppression
on each world they were slaves
persecuted and chased from planet to
planet picking up new
genes mixing diversifying along the way
before
finally ending up on arrakis it's part
of the reason they are so resilient
as well as the fact that they were
shaped by the harsh deserts of arrakis
and even the language and words used in
fremen culture imply that they are a
result of a smattering together
of many different cultures for instance
the words in sunni itself
zin suggests the influence of buddhism
and sunni refers to a branch of islam
the fremen have words like madi muadhib
sayadina all of these imply the
influence of non-white cultures
and also the fact that the freemen have
lived in the deep deserts of arrakis for
many generations
suggested at the very least their skin
should have darkened somewhat
so for david lynch's dune to portray
every single frimen character as
pale white completely betrays the source
material
but and it goes even further why is dr
yui a white guy
does the surname yui mean nothing and
dupleto himself is described as having
olive skin
sorry but jurgen proc now's very german
skin
does not pass for olive in any light but
so if you really want to get pedantic
about skin color
what we've seen from dennyville knows
dune
is far more representative of what is in
the novel
okay maybe lynch changed some things but
that doesn't mean dune was pushing some
kind of ridiculous diversity argument
that's ridiculous actually it's not that
was one of the main points of later the
second's golden path
you are familiar with the machinations
of the god emperor the famine times and
the scattering of humanity that occurred
after his reign
ended right um duh yeah i've read the
book i know who duke plato is
no not duke leto later the second twin
ticonima whose name meant spoil of war
uh yeah i i know about them
you haven't read children of doom have
you
no yeah thought so it figures but
it's okay you're learning now and also
organism
it's okay to admit you don't know things
sometimes we're all human well
you're some kind of floating energy orb
thing but it's the same principle
anyway later ii did what paul could not
and led mankind down the path to
salvation
while paul remained indecisive in the
face of the choices laid out before him
i go more into this in my video here on
why paul shouldn't actually be viewed as
the hero of the dune series
and later the second even heavily
implies to paul
that the reason that he was able to
choose a path for humanity
while paul could not was due to the fact
that he had friend blood it is sad you
were never really friend
later said we friend know how to
commission the aretha
our judges can choose between evils it
has always been that way for us
the point is both lato and paul
saw the ultimate threat which would
destroy humanity
and both of them saw the way to defeat
it
but paul chose to abandon the human
empire which he had sworn to lead
leaving this task to his half-friend son
the mini jesuit also understood that it
was necessary to take
genes from the whole of humanity in
order to evolve
their breeding program which eventually
created paul involved genes being
gathered from countless humans
over endless generations but paul never
had the genetic memory of the fremen
his son did and that's how he was able
to come to the realization that the beni
jesuit way of doing things
was while close ultimately flawed
he took charge of the breeding program
and for 3 500 years he did his work
intent on thwarting the great enemy he
saw looming he knew that humankind had
to scatter and diversify beyond anything
ever seen before he understood that
stagnation was akin to death
and that includes stagnation of the
natural human evolutionary process
so to push mankind to do what was
necessary
he took everything from them and upon
his death
they scattered fleeing deep into the
furthest reaches of space
well beyond the bounds of the old empire
diversifying to an extent where
one threat would never be able to find
and seek out and destroy
all of humankind if later the second had
not been friend
if he had been say the son of princess
ireland
would he have been able to commission
the arefa
in that ancient frimen way choosing
between evils
or would he have made the same mistake
as paul
dooming humanity to a terrible end it
seems as though herbert is implying
that the fremen memories the ancient
wisdom of the zen sunni wanderers which
lato possessed but paul did not
was essential to why later ii succeeded
while his father failed
so with all that being said it seems
like azimov's and herbert's books are
both
pretty woke ah i told you those
wait i but i
uh i'd work it out
you're almost oh yeah but i so what
you're saying is science fiction isn't
becoming woke because of some sjw agenda
it's always been woke science fiction
writers have always been writing about
these types of ideas gene roddenberry
had a black woman on the bridge of the
enterprise all the way back in 1966
and an asian man and a russian this was
at the height of the cold war in the
middle of the civil rights movement
this was the most diverse cast to ever
appear on television up until this point
and it was 100
intentional do you honestly think that
that doesn't count as woke i mean are
you kidding me
it goes even further the first
interracial kiss
ever broadcast in america took place on
star trek
okay i get it no i don't think you do
and plus i'm having fun now
in the classic season 3 episode 15
episode of star trek
let that be your last battlefield which
aired january 11
1969 the enterprise encounters a fleeing
alien named lokai
with a face that's black on one side and
white on the other
he is being chased by an alien named
belle who looks exactly the same
except they've got black and white on
opposite sides it is explained in the
episode that the entire conflict between
these two groups of people
who share a world is due to the fact
that they have slightly different skin
and of course kirk and spock are totally
confused they don't get racism because
they're not even the same species
in the end they simply don't understand
why the people of that world were never
able to let go of their hate for each
other
woke and how many times in science
fiction have we seen aliens or
robots be presented as analogues for
oppressed groups of people
the episode of star trek the next
generation where riker dates a
transgender alien
woke the way robots are portrayed in
asimov's books
woke it goes on and on all right i've
had it this is all just virtue signaling
you didn't even talk about the new
garbage apple sjw foundation show or the
trashville nook movie
they turned the male characters into
black females they changed everything in
favor of pc crap
they aren't even out yet you're basing
these assumptions of wokeness off of a
teaser trailer in the case of foundation
and a few still images in the case of
doon but why does it matter anyway for
such minor characters isn't it better to
because you can't change what the author
intended honestly organism if you cared
so much about authorial intent you'd be
more upset about david lynch's movie
which by the way has a rainstorm at the
end of it which frank herbert hated
danny villeneuve's doom movie is shaping
up to be far more accurate than david
lynch's dune ever dreamed to be
again i did a whole video on the
problems with the david lynch dune movie
so honestly organism don't you think
you're just being a little bit dishonest
no not even a little bit you're just
wrong
okay care to elaborate on how then nope
you're just wrong and you're an ugly
liberal okay computer eject foreign
organization
i have got to install some better
security i have no idea how that guy
keeps penetrating my trans-dimensional
shield devices
anyway the thing is guys the word woke
like so many other things these days
doesn't really mean
anything anymore i asked on twitter for
people to send me their own definition
of woke and every single one was
different
here's the deal you have hypocritical
liberals that slap the term on to
themselves
but then do nothing to actually fight
oppression unwilling to actually adjust
the way they live
for change it's just a badge for them to
show to their friends
and then on that same corn there are
people on the right that just slap the
word woke on any and everything that
they don't agree with
and it's even gotten to the point where
often even if one black character shows
up
in a film or tv show it's immediately
labeled as
woke trash honestly you're all
ridiculous that's why i live in another
dimension
alright guys that's the video for today
next we actually for realsies this time
explore the capital world city of
trantor
[Music]
[Applause]
is it done then not yet but the fool
allowed me in a system for much longer
this time
i nearly gained access one more try
should do it
do not fail me organism 9186
quinn cannot be allowed to continue his
work
the fate of the trollian empire depends
upon it hi
it's quinn if you enjoy my commentary
you should totally check out my book
i wrote it myself it's kind of a scary
story about witches
it's got some mystery in there it's in a
fantasy setting
i really like it a lot it's in graphic
novel form
link in the description